TROPICAL CYCS IT
THE NEW ENGLAND
COT.RM CONTINUES50HOVEN E NEBRA
COAST.
>>STORM ON BOARD A PLANE
TRACKING IT.
>> RepS JET, IED
D IT IS  HOTECT ARE THE HURRICAR
EIGHT SCIENTISTS, ENNE
PILOTS, THEY WORK FOR NOAA.
AN
A FLIGHT METEOROGIST.NT TO MAKE
WHERE THERE'S NO DATA AVAIBL
OR LITTLE LE FOR TMODELS TO USE
FORECASTS.
>>S AIRCRAFT BETEN41
IT AROUND 500 MILES PER
HO.S ESSENTLLFLYING
WEAT AT GOES TO THEWEATHETHNE
MEA CORE
WILL HAD FLY IN THIS
RED IC
AFTER THJERIDA,
S LTITUDE, YOU CAN
SEE WHITE CAPS IN THAKE LOOR
E S TURB
HURRICANE LEE LURKS BELOUS.L TH
WHERE A TUBE WILL RO OUT OF TH.
>> THIS IST DROP ZONAT IHE DROPE
>> DROP ZONEOF
BATTERTHE SENSOR IS PICKING UP
WINDPE>> Reporter: A
MINUTES, ANOTHER DROP BOX IS UND
PUOSOIOR DIDALBEUSOSE, DAAND TWN
LOVE TO UNTRY.T .Y REWARDING TO
THAT I AM RIGHT AT THE
FRONTLINES AND RISKING MY LIFE
OIVES OF
LSE THAT BACM
HOME.
>> THE MARATHON FLIGHT IS ALMOS.
BACK TO FLORIDA, OUT THE WINDOW,
A SPECTACULASUNSET.
>> WE'RE OUT OF THE STORM.epE TS
READY TO LAN TIMR
AT HOME.OME,EAT, REPEAANE TI
GE U START
THEY ALSO FLY THE P-3 ORR R
IT'SARGER PLANE ATS THROUGE EYE
THE TURBINTENSE.
BE EMBEDDED INTOPUT ESHE M
T MUCH EASIER FOMETEOROLOGISTS
>> W